[Music]  don't speak english  full screen  [Music]  hey all right american express card  don't leave home without it hey get out  of here  all right let's beat it man i don't like  it up here what are you scared of  heights  i don't know after what happened to  johnny garb  hey look man johnny gobbs got ripped and  took a walk off a roof all right  no big loss no man that ain't what i  heard at all  i heard the bat got him the bat oh man  give me a break will you  five stories straight down there wasn't  no blood in the body  no [ __ ] it was all over the pavement  [Music]  shut up man listen to me darry know  that yeah we shouldn't turn the gun on  that kid man you shouldn't have turned a  gun in it  or not now shut up shut  [Music]  up  [Music]  don't kill me don't kill me man  don't kill me don't kill me man i'm not  going to kill you  i want you to do me a favor i want you  to tell all your friends about me  what are you i'm batman  [Music]  you